so this one is um how to model a
lightning strike
we're going to try and make an animation
of the lightning strike that looks
realistic
and i'm not claiming that it is a
realistic model of lightning
yeah this is this is kind of secretly a
demonstration of an algorithm in
computer science called breadth first
search
which we'll be showing as like a maze
solving algorithm
so what we have is a it's a frontier of
exploration bits of lightning and one of
them
hits the ground first and that the path
that that one followed ends up being the
shape of the lightning strike
so like a frontier of exploration
and as soon as you find it
that one gets reinforced and that
becomes a lightning strike and
this is taking place inside a randomly
generated labyrinth
so maybe the walls inside this maze
would correspond to fluctuations in the
air like very variations in the
resistance or how charges can pass
through
the air and maybe if air was perfectly
homogeneous it would just be lightning
would always be a straight line i don't
know
it's really good looking this one isn't
it we were you pleased with how it
turned out once you've made it did you
think wow that looks awesome yeah i
think it's quite like um satisfying i
think there's a there's a bit of there's
a kind of game at the beginning where
you're like well which one's going to
win and you know in some of these you've
got two kind of
two or three competing parts and is this
one going to win this is going to and
then that one wins in the end and then
you you have the satisfying bullet of
lightning at the end your cat seems
really
into it
yeah
helps me out with all of these
animations this is done in mathematica
the first stage is generating the random
maze
then there's solving the maze and then
there's generating the animation from
the solution so here we are in
mathematica this is code to randomly
generate a maze which we're visualizing
here so maybe you can see if i run this
every time
i'm going to get a random
configuration
of of walls in the maze how do you know
the maze is always going to be solvable
what i would do is just generate it
again again until it is solvable since
it's random
basically it turns out it'd be quite
unlucky
if it's not solvable but i could be
unlucky and then
the
the output of the breadth for a search
will be there is no solution to this
maze and i'll say okay let's generate
another random one the way this works is
that we're going to be working on a
square grid here are all the points that
might be connected by lines of a square
and then each
each of these
potential lines here will either be free
or there will be a wall of the maze you
know there's one probability for each of
these
uh being
joined being joined yeah and then
there's another there's a different
probability for the horizontal ones and
i did that just because i wanted to make
it more likely to be solvable
so these have a these have a different
probability q say of being
joined and then i just set it so that
you know i'd set it so that q
was less likely than than p there are
more vertical lines than horizontal
lines yeah there should be but there
might not be
so then there is the
the step to solve
the maze you know that's this code here
it's relatively easy to just sort of
show how it works i think so say we have
some
maze and
what we're asking is we're going to
start at a point at the top right
and
our goal is to get down to
the bottom so you know lightning is
somewhere in the cloud and we just need
to get anywhere on the ground we've got
various
walls that are
joined this might be enough to get
the idea you know theoretically we could
just solve this by trying all possible
paths to the bottom but we could be more
efficient than that and the the idea is
that we're just going to take it one
step at a time we know that we're
starting
in this
cell so we can get there in zero steps
now we can get to
this one in one step and get to this
cell in two steps we can get to the cell
in three steps and to this on four steps
now we've got a branching point and this
might be where you would be worried that
okay now our code is going to go off in
this and go uh be intractable but really
let's just take it one step at a time
and just record how how far we can get
this cell we can get to in five steps
and we can also get to this one in five
steps now where can we get to in six
steps we can get here you can get here
or we can get here and how far can we
get in seven steps you know there's a
box up here we can get to here we could
go right or down here we could go down
you know and eventually we're going to
have some kind of path that goes
something like this now that we've got
to the bottom what that's told is it is
there's a path to the bottom that only
takes 10 steps so let's not bother
looking at all the 11 steps ones because
we know how to get there in 10 all we
need is the shortest path
it's called breadth first search breadth
first search yeah breadth first and
that's as opposed to depth first what
happens in your code if there's a tie
yeah that's a good question in that case
it will just be down to um
basically random or the way that i
implemented the code you know maybe i
looked at paths to the left before it's
passed down or to the right and so i'll
just pick a tie so yeah it's not so it's
it's ambiguous yeah okay so here
you know before we generated one and it
looks like we were lucky and there is a
path that goes down
so yeah so this was the original maze
and now this is solving the maze and
just visualizing the path
which
it's maybe a bit hard to see because
it doesn't
correspond with uh with that but um
you know maybe i could quickly
draw them on top of each other
let's make the path red
we solve this original maze and this is
this ended up being
the shortest path or one of the shortest
paths so matthew the animation that you
ended up publishing is just an arbitrary
one that the codes spat out randomly
that you liked the look of yeah i did a
couple on a smaller maze and a couple in
a bigger maze and i ran a few and those
ones seemed like interesting ones where
there was some
kind of race going on in in the
lightning and yeah they just ones that
looked nice i thought so we could look
at the one that we happen to randomly
generate there
but the third step in the code is
just sort of drawing the picture
in a nice way so we'll be using all the
numbers that we had
to color the frontier as time progresses
so if for example the sixes were kind of
interesting because we had the frontier
at one point will look like this we'll
have all the sixes and i will i will
color them so that this
bottom six will be brighter
than this top six because in some sense
it's more promising winning is winning
in some way
even though it lost in the end i guess
because he it was it this six
looped lower in his winning but ends up
losing because there's a better path
starting going along from that sex yeah
so that's what the animation here
does so you start just creating
so you're coloring equal numbers
basically yeah that's right and i think
there's a bit of fuzziness as well so
i'm maybe drawing here i'm drawing all
the
well i can find out
all the 16s
but i'm the 15s are still fading out of
existence at that point and this is the
most promising 16 which maybe looks like
a dead end actually
yeah so
yeah yeah so then this actually becomes
more promising and this one isn't you
know coming into
existence this is so much fun i feel
like you could just sit there like
betting on it or like you just sort of
in your mind you're running a little oh
is it going to win which one's going to
win
i still don't know oh that one that one
down the middle
no yes
no yes you got it and then there's that
of course that was a solution right
this is so satisfying to watch these i
could watch these all day
so and then we can change things like we
could make the maze bigger smaller
bigger or smaller should we try why not
i got nowhere to be
let's say we could make it not square as
well i suppose
do you want a wide and
thin or tall and i think tall yeah total
is more fun shortly let's make make it
the same but twice as tall
okay so now we have
so quick just a couple k strokes yeah
but let's see if we can solve it as
quickly
no so i think this means that it was an
unsolvable maze
listen my code
creates this nice red box if it's
unsolvable so let's try again so
we would just regenerate this is a new
maze
can you tell is it solvable
i can't tell i
think
i think there is a path down here
i think so you're gonna get the red box
of dome
no no
and that's what it looks like in the
context of of the original maze
and and will animite as well
should they
okay
here we go oh we've got two kind of
parallel
so it looks like there were two they
were very close and we ended up picking
this one yeah so there were two that
were two there were two winners but they
chose them
that is fun that is seriously fun but
just to be clear you're not a
meteorologist and you're not claiming
this is how real lightning works it just
looks like lightning yeah this is not an
accurate model of lightning when i
posted this animation it did get a lot
of attention from meteorologists and it
sort of got retweeted around the world
of american
weather presenters
i'm worried that i've convinced them
that this is how lightning works
this episode's been supported by kiwiko
now in the past you've seen me making
all sorts of cool stuff this time i've
shared the love and had kiwi co send a
crate to my nephew sebastian you can see
his co-pilot here is chelsea together
they're putting together a domino
machine this crate's targeted at ages
nine plus perfect for ten-year-old seb
but there's a whole range of crates
available on the site for people of all
ages
everything you need is home delivered
already in the box
it's so enriching to expose young minds
to science and engineering and
technologies in ways like this
but you don't have to take my word for
it
just look here at sebastian
whether it's for yourself or maybe as a
gift check out kiwiko and there's 50 off
the first month of your subscription by
going to kiwico.com
number five there on the screen
kiwico.com
numberphile and there is one very happy
creator and his domino laying machine
even sebastian's little brother got some
value from this one
let's say and i'm here right i can't go
left or right here i can't go left or
right here i can't go left and right
here and i'm spending a lot of time
going to this one adding it to the queue
to this one and then and going down here
i'm taking one two three four steps when
really one step would have sufficed okay
where are you going i hope your eyes are
closed okay and they are there okay
start with a draw
okay oh right over there
there there's one okay so we have edward
sabine referee reports by jb airy on
some of his papers let's choose the
lunar tired one and the magnetism one